s'il ya bien un nom qui résonne en ce
moment dans les couloirs de france 2
c'est celui de l'animatrice faustine
bollaert
la discrète animatrice transfuge de m6
depuis 2017 a su séduire les
téléspectateurs du service public et par
conséquent sa direction merci votre
attention coaching et m6 sont arrivés
fotsing aulas prend la tête de
l'émission de confident ça commence
aujourd'hui un programme qui depuis
quatre saisons recueille chaque
après-midi des témoignages très fort à
cette mouvance
l'émission qui rassemble régulièrement
un million de fidèles une très bonne
odeur pour la case des audiences qui ont
donné confiance à france télévisions qui
a décidé de confier une émission en
prime time à l'animatrice avec la boîte
à secrets diffusés sur france 3 faustine
continue de séduire les téléspectateurs
c'est parti la dernière émission a même
battu son propre record d'audience avec
2 millions 3 123 mille fidèles devant
les confidences d'avenir et d'anne
roumanoff
je pensais pas mais là je suis
complètement j'ai peur en fait
autre programme port dont elle est la
maître de cérémonie les victoires de la
musique est une belle vitrine pour
l'animatrice qui en quelques années
semble avoir réussi à s'imposer comme un
visage fort du groupe france télévisions
alors faustine bollaert
l'étoile montante de france télévisions
alors étoile montante oui ou non alors
alors il ya quand même deux noms
pourquoi kevin vatant facile ça fait
quinze ans qu'elle fait de la télé c'est
une étoile montante allemande que
doucement
appelé comme rappelé que ce fut d'abord
elle faisait plus qu'elle en audience à
l'été un million trois là on est sur un
million en moyenne quand elle a quitté
le meilleur pâtissier n'a jamais obligé
1 millions 3 comment je viens me en
trois mois mercredi elle a battu toutes
les chaînes mercredi mais en moyenne en
voyage vous dire magnéto sur le sur le
long terme du joual a quitté le meilleur
pâtissier balade mission n'a jamais
aussi bien marché qu'aujourd'hui ça m'a
dit oui ce n'est pas une étoile montante
ce n'est pas une découverte force india
place de gens qui ont eu un début de
carrière pas forcément exceptionnel pour
notre patron jerry fait comme si dans
l'avenir des conditions kevin a été
vachement dur avec fais moi je les adore
choquer minier a plein d'infos mais moi
je voulais juste te dire
qu'effectivement je trouvais que c'était
l'étoile montante de france télé et
surtout ce sera la digne héritière pour
moi de sophie davant effectivement sur
m6 je pense qu'elle n'avait pas sa place
m6 vous savez un moment ils pressent un
petit peu trop leurs animateurs c'est ce
qui s'était passé avec faustine elle
s'était planté avec leurs émissions de
murs là avec les chanteurs et thoune à
main c'était résine d'eau c'était rising
donne exactement et je pense qu'à un
moment elle a peut-être eu un petit
manque de confiance ce qui s'explique
parce que ça marchait pas trop bien pour
elle sur m6 mais elle a trouvé sa
nouvelle maison et je la trouve
formidable a lui même déjà tu as faux
sur toute la ligne quand elle a pris la
casse wang bollaert avec ça commence
aujourd'hui elle était complètement
déserté donc déjà réussir à faire un
million un million 3 c'est exceptionnel
l'immersion qu'elle veut d'avant l'une
en trois moyens de le messager le samedi
soir la boîte à secrets par l'émission
de noël qui a fait lui servir après midi
c'est pareil c'est pas l'après midi
c'est bien arrivé dans ce noël chambre
quoi qu'il en soit france tenait
effectivement compte beaucoup sur l là
ils sont en train de préparer un prince
de témoignages arrêt savent pas encore
s'ils savent être un sac et ça commence
aujourd'hui en prime notre cas serait
une émission de témoignages elle à une
autre émission qui arrivent et moi je
suis désolé mais moi j'ai besoin de
nahla comme festival exactement à ce que
pour la connaître un petit peu
personnellement lorsqu'on est ancien
personnage très bien fait sinon morizet
mission superbe bouzid il ya par exemple
tu vois cet après midi avait un ça
commence aujourd'hui sur l'alcoolisme
sur le papier tu te dis super je vais
avec moi ça voulait coucher ça a fait
ses comptes
comment ils semblent sorties donc ces
supports président national et sa
superbe mais tu vas en tant
qu'animatrice préférant il l'entend
demande à emilie lopez quelle est la
qualité de faustine bollaert elle dit
c'est quelqu'un de bien
bah oui parce qu'elle n'a aucune qualité
comme animatrice c'est pas la seule
émission que sait faire faustine
bollaert
c'est une émission lacrymal où tout le
monde pleure a révélé à décliner dans
tous les cas ces jo ont fait pleurer les
gens en ce moment ça marche mais sega
pas il n'y a pas de griffes propre bras
de qualité propres si simplement
pleurent tous est donc arrivée certains
on a un bon avocat en un bon avocat mike
king est ni l émission lacrymal je suis
d'accord mais émission testimoniale
c'est l'arrêt tiers non seulement de ce
fait d'abord mais aussi de jean luc
delarue et sur les émissions
testimoniale tu évoquais les débuts
compliqués sur la case oui elle a débuté
en août 2007 à 600 milles elle a
multiplié la case en réseau nas de part
de quelques breaks mardi quelques mois
si ça va moi qui avais la belle histoire
l afem finissait sa licence de
journalistes elle a pu rencontrer jean
luc delarue est lui a dit un jour mon
rêve c'est de présenter une émission de
témoignages et ces définitions avec la
productrice van hamme et lé avec les
alcools et yves baillot pour moi le
l'étoile montante de france 2 ça restera
michel drucker parce que depuis le
satellite avec la télé comme jean pierre
pernaut baston mais ils vont avec le
poste j'en passe la une à la deux il ya
jean pierre pernaut il ya michel drucker